auch jungen Leuten kann das Corona-Virus
gefährlich werden in Frankreich ist
jetzt an 16-jähriges Mädchen an Kubik 19
gestorben dennoch glauben viele immer
noch dass nur ältere und Menschen mit
Vorerkrankungen gefährdet sind doch das
ist ein fataler Trugschluss und jetzt
gibt es erst Indizien die Anhaltspunkte
für schwere und leichte Verläufe liefern
Klicks und Science Fiction hier gibt's
täglich spannende science Videos
abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert die
Glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen wenn dieser Tage den
New Yorker Gouverneur Andrew como bei
CNN gesehen hat dem könnte es Respekt
vor dieser Krankheit einflößen seine
Botschaft auch wenn man einen
schwächeren Verlauf der Erkrankung hat
ist Covic 19 eine ziemlich Angst
einflößende Infektion denn die Symptome
können auch wenn sie einen nicht das
Leben kosten sehr heftig sein so erlebt
er es gerade er hat sich angesteckt und
kann jetzt nicht mehr an vorderster
Front gegen das Virus kämpfen sondern
befindet sich in häuslicher Quarantäne
die Krankheit ist wirklich ziemlich
umkalkulierbar und es ist auf den es
geht nur schwer zu verstehen manche
Menschen die mit dem Virus sarskopf 2
infiziert sind merken sogar kaum oder
gar nichts davon vielleicht fühlt man
sich etwas schlapper als sonst oder hat
Halsschmerzen tausende andere Menschen
dagegen sind weltweit bereits an der
Erkrankung kobit 19 gestorben die
Schäden an der Lunge sind bei ihnen so
groß dass sie keine Luft mehr bekommen
einen Kreislaufschock erleiden oder aber
das Herz versagt es handelt sich also um
Krankheitsverläufe die eine extrem große
Spannweite aufweisen und genau das ist
charakteristisch für das neuartige Virus
es macht den Eindruck als ob ihr das
Alter ein entscheidendes Kriterium sei
junge Menschen und vor allem Kinder
stecken die Erkrankung meistens besser
weg als ältere dazu die
Wissenschaftlerin Ulrike protzer aus
München wir haben noch nicht verstanden
weshalb der Verlauf bei älteren
infizierten schwerer ist Kinder aber in
den meisten Fällen kaum Symptome zeigen
in der Wissenschaftscommunity gibt es
bislang nur Vermutungen warum der
Krankheitsverlauf bei sehr jungen
Menschen im Großteil der Fälle eher mild
ist möglicherweise ist dies begründet
dass der Körper von Kleinkindern sehr
gut auf den Erstkontakt mit neuen Keimen
ausgerichtet ist denn das ist ja der
Hauptjob des Immunsystems in den ersten
Lebensjahren das Immunsystem von älteren
Menschen dagegen kann vor allem
auftrumpfen wenn es auf Erfahrungen
zurückgreifen kann denn so können
bereits vorhandene Immunzellen schnell
reaktiviert und vermehrt werden um gegen
ähnliche Viren loszulegen doch genau
hier liegt das Problem denn das
Coronavirus ist dem menschlichen
Immunsystem gänzlich unbekannt je älter
die Menschen sind umso weniger gut kann
die Krankheitsabwehr also mit diesem
Erreger umgehen es dauert viel zu lange
ehe die wichtigen Immunzellen neu
gebildet werden das Virus bereitet sich
also im menschlichen Körper aus und das
ungehindert wir sind vor allem
diejenigen mit einem geschwächten
Immunsystem gefährdet und eben auch
ältere Menschen sind dem Viren oft
schutzlos ausgeliefert doch sicher ist
niemand denn wie das
Robert-Koch-Institut schreibt kommen
schwere Verläufe diese Erkrankungen eben
auch bei jungen Menschen vor ebenso auch
bei Menschen ohne Vorerkrankung daher
auch die Warnung des
gesundheitssekretärs der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation Tetris
aschernom an die junge Generation ihr
seid nicht unverwundbar sein Appell an
alle jungen soziale Kontakte meiden und
auf Abstand gehen stay at home und
Social distancing also dem kann auch der
Münchner Arzt Clemens Wenter zustimmen
er hat die ersten corona-fälle in
Deutschland behandelt nicht nur ältere
sondern auch junge Menschen landen in
seiner Klinik auf der Intensivstation
der Mediziner sagt in einem
zeitinterview wir müssen auch junge
Menschen künstlich beatmen die sind in
ihren 20ern und 30ern und mussten nach
wenigen Stunden in der Notaufnahme
intubiert werden daher auch die Warnung
die jungen Menschen sind nicht
unverwundbar manche wiegen sich da in
einer Sicherheit die es nicht gibt das
zeigt jetzt auch ein dramatischer Fall
aus Frankreich dort ist ein 16-jähriges
Mädchen an kubit 19 gestorben Schwester
und Mutter warnen jetzt Zitat niemand
ist gegen dieses mutierte Virus
unbesiegbar laut dem französischen
Gesundheitsministeriums war es wohl eine
besonders aggressive Form des
Coronavirus diese sei allerdings extrem
selten bei jungen Leuten so die Angaben
der Behörde auch in anderen Ländern
wurden bereits Todesfälle durch COBIT 19
bei Jüngern Menschen ohne
Vorerkrankungen gemeldet unter anderem
aus Italien Spanien und den USA wie und
warum ist hier zu solchen schweren
Krankheitsverläufen kam ist noch nicht
abschließend geklärt möglicherweise
liegt es aber daran dass das Virus
direkt in die Lunge eingeatmet wurde so
bekam der Körper nicht die Möglichkeit
sich auf die Erreger vorzubereiten
normalerweise beginnt die Kurve 19
Erkrankung im Rachen und die Viren
vermehren sich dort einige Tage bevor
sie in die Lunge gelangen in diesem Fall
bekommt das Immunsystem also zumindest
einige Zeit um Antikörper zu bilden
welche Medikamente gegen Corona helfen
sehr fundiertes Video von Spektrum Video
hier anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
und zwar den top-kanal das
wissenschaftsverlagsspektrum in unserem
wissenschaftsnetzwerk Essen 1054 also
pflichtabo hier draufklicken bis dann
bleibt